well we have to start today with the
little red wave that couldn't what was
that kid's Story the The Little Engine
That Could This was very much the
opposite this ended up being the little
red wave that was a ripple so small that
Democrats may actually gain seats in the
Senate Democrats have won the Senate yes
we do not yet know the results of the
house we're going to talk uh on the
bonus show about the specific scenarios
that could end up prevailing in the
house but over in the Senate it is over
in the sense that Democrats have indeed
secured a majority the question now
becomes is it a 50 50 majority with
Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking vote
or is it a 5149 majority which would be
very important
if we want to make Joe manchin
irrelevant and we are going to get to
that but the final numbers uh in the
Nevada Senate race coming in over the
weekend as well as the calling of the
Arizona race and this is how Democrats
got to 50. Mark Kelly did defeat Blake
Masters in Arizona there is still six
percent of the vote to be counted there
but with Kelly's lead of over 125 000
votes it has been called this is really
great news for the country when it comes
to being marginally less humiliated on
an international stage Blake Masters the
Challenger to Mark Kelly the man who won
the Republican primary an absolute
humiliation just a pathetic embarrassing
horrible candidate didn't make any sense
from the extreme magowing almost as bad
as Carrie Lake quite frankly and we'll
get to Kerry Lake don't worry we have
plenty on Kerry Lake coming up a little
bit later that was number 49
uh we have in Georgia as we will talk
about Rafael Warnock and Herschel Walker
December 6th there will be a runoff much
of our focus and attention and resources
are going to go there and number 50
indeed from the state of Nevada where
Cortez masto the Democratic incumbent
has come out ahead of Challenger Adam
laxalt it is a 6500 vote lead with 98 in
it has been called there is not a 50
rule in the state of Nevada remember
that in Georgia there is a runoff
because of Georgia law that says the
winner must get 50 of the vote
in Nevada there is no such law and with
48.8 percent of the vote Cortez masto is
number 50 and Democrats have won the
Senate now there is going to be all
sorts of after the fact armchair
quarterbacking prognostication
reprognostication whatever the case may
be a couple of story lines that are
coming up and some of them I've dealt
with myself on Twitter which by the way
is barely functional anymore under Elon
Musk Twitter is quite frankly a disaster
at this point let's put that aside
um some of you coming forward and saying
even to me sir you were wrong about the
coming Red Wave you were you need to
apologize as usual some in my audience
obsessed with me even though I have
nothing to do with this let's review
what had been my message in the last
three to four weeks going into this
election I told you
the momentum has shifted in the
direction of Republicans the momentum
has shifted that being said many
individual races when you look at their
average polling have a bunch of
right-leaning polls included in them and
it is making me and others suspect that
some of these forecasts which include
these right-leaning polls May overstate
the degree of of momentum in the
direction of Republicans and in the last
week I very specifically said
whatever is the truth about these polls
it's over the polls are a tool earlier
on to give us a sense of the direction
and momentum when we are seven five
three one day away from the election
if the polls are right or the polls are
wrong we have to go and vote and thanks
to a lot of 18 to 20 or 29 year olds
which we will talk about a little bit
later the Red Wave was at most a red
Ripple we will see what happens in the
house very very soon but Democrats will
control the Senate now the question is
50 or 51. I got a number of emails from
folks over the weekend
saying David we don't have to worry
about the Senate anymore we don't have
to worry about the Senate because Adam
laxalt was defeated by Cortez masto in
Nevada
and Democrats now have guaranteed
a majority 50 50 in the Senate and that
is true but 51 versus 50 is of massive
importance 51 means that Joe manchin or
Kirsten cinema right but Joe manchin's
been the bigger problem is no longer
necessary on votes that require a simple
majority
and it means you only need nine
Republicans instead of ten when you need
60 votes in the Senate this cannot be
understated so let's talk through it
when it comes to federal judges as an
example it is of critical importance
that Democrats control the Senate
and Democrats do and those are simple
majorities and generally speaking
neither Joe manchin or Kirsten Cinema
have been obstacles when it comes to
those sorts of votes but there are all
sorts of other bills and proposals where
Mansion has been a problem and Mansion
has done the rounds on the Sunday shows
and has made himself into this decider
for lack of a better term because
Democrats were able to coalesce 49 votes
but not 50 specifically because of Joe
manchin if indeed Raphael Warnock
defeats Herschel Walker in the December
6th runoff one Senator you could take
your pick Mansion or Cinema no longer
matters when you simply need 50 plus
Kamala Harris's tie-breaking vote
there's another really important reason
why this runoff is still important even
though Democrats now control the Senate
either way
and that is that 2024 is a much more
difficult Senate map and Georgia would
be one seat that does not have to be won
in 2024 in order to maintain a majority
consider that we've been talking about
the 2024 senate election for years 33
Senate seats are up in 2024 and it is
not a good map for Democrats Democrats
have to defend seats in Montana Ohio and
West Virginia John tester in Montana a
Democrat Montana is very very red he won
with 50.3 percent last time really
really Slim margin Sherrod Brown in Ohio
a Democrat one with 53 percent in 2018 a
little more margin there but still not
an easy race and then in West Virginia
Joe manchin won with under 50 think
about that with under 50 and with Joe
manchin and West Virginia being such a
red State we don't even know whether Joe
manchin is is running yet I don't have
the latest uh I believe the latest
information is Mansion is not yet
committed to running in 2024 if Mansion
doesn't run
and it comes down to a further left
Democrat versus a republican in West
Virginia
it very well may be that that is a seat
that Democrat my earpiece is flopping
all over that even me may be a seat that
Democrats uh potentially give up so the
Senate map is so tough in 2024 that
controlling the senate in 24 may depend
on whether Rafael Warnock or Herschel
Walker win on December 6th so I I think
I'm making the stakes pretty clear here
last thing on this imagine if for the
last two years
Democrats had had 51 rather than 50
votes and the number of bills on which
the entire circus side show with Joe
manchin could have been skipped
altogether so this is still an
absolutely critical runoff for different
reasons than it was critical 48 or 72
hours ago we're going to be doing live
streams getting involved in that race
many of you are saying I actually should
go to Georgia
I just don't know that I can do it in in
the next you know couple weeks with
everything I have going on but we are
going to do as much as we can on that
race and more information about that
upcoming you know we always say
if only the young people came out and
voted especially in the midterms look at
what we could do well we have the
numbers 18 to 29 year olds saved the
election last Tuesday there is a really
great explanation from uh John de la
Volpe I hope I'm uh pronouncing that
correctly where de la Volpe explains the
simple math okay High turnout
combined with 63 percent of 18 to 29
year olds voting for Democrats versus 35
percent of that very same group voting
for Republicans gen Z and the younger
Millennials under 30 effectively
canceled out every voter age 65 plus
this is absolutely fascinating and then
when you look at these groups you look
at 18 to 29
and you look at 65 plus 18 to 29 had a
plus three overall contribution to the
vote margin for Democrats and 65 plus
had a minus three overall contribution
for Democrats we always talk about the
older Generations are significantly more
right-leaning and there's just not
enough young people voting to cancel out
or make up for that that is exactly what
that's literally what happened on
November 8th the very uh uh same
three-point contribution that the 65
plus group overall made to Republicans
was eliminated it was zeroed out it was
teared as we might say uh by 18 to 29
year olds who contributed a three-point
margin to Democrats it was their own
future on the line I wish that they
would vote more and it's important to
focus on the fact that it's not
record-breaking numbers necessarily that
make the difference here it's that
enough young people turned out to vote
in order to undo the significant
right-leaning effect of the 65 plus
group at the end of the day uh 53
percent of eligible voters voted in the
2018 midterms uh in 2022
only 27 percent of those in that
youngest age group voted so consider
that comparison there is so much
Headroom for that youngest group to get
more involved and I know it's so cliche
because we always say look at the math
if that young group got more involved
they could wield so much power and
influence well we are seeing it 18 to 29
year olds canceled out the 65 plus vote
the Red Wave evaporated it will maybe be
a ripple and the amount of Headroom that
that group has to single-handedly decide
elections is incredible we've just got
to engage them we've got to get them
involved make sure you're subscribed to
our YouTube channel very important we're
pushing for 2 million subscribers we
will be live tomorrow night with Trump's
announcement on YouTube twitch and
Facebook hope to see you there
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show does depend on
your support to do what we do I would
love for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com become a member it comes
with great benefits it's very
inexpensive and it directly funds what
we do there's no other parties taking
big slices of every contribution the way
many of these large Tech platforms do
two percent goes to processing credit
and debit cards a very reasonable amount
and the rest actually stays with us you
can sign up at joinpakman.com and you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now
because it does and let's get to that
right away Ron DeSantis now leads Donald
Trump in the 2024 betting markets now as
I as I always do because I don't want
any confusion on this these are not
polls these are people betting who do
you believe will be the Republican
Presidential nominee and although the
numbers themselves have fluctuated the
money is behind DeSantis and Trump
almost exclusively the next person down
is Nikki Haley and she's almost nowhere
she's she's in the toilet right to use
the language that these folks use and it
has been a head-to-head between Trump
and DeSantis Trump leading that for much
of the last year but it is now for many
days straight and every day since the
2022 midterm has been DeSantis DeSantis
DeSantis now I don't believe for a
second that this proves DeSantis will be
the nominee and in fact one of the
things I think
is important to think realistically
about is do we really believe that in a
national campaign
if it's the Trump of 2016's Republican
primary with the insults and the
aggressiveness and the attacks and the
ridiculing of the other candidates do we
really think that in a national race
DeSantis can actually stand up to the
bully Trump DeSantis to me although he's
a horrible person
wrong on most issues
completely disagree with him politically
all these different things I don't
actually know that DeSantis can get down
in the mud
uh down in the toilet water with Trump
the way you probably need to in order to
actually defeat Donald Trump in a far in
a hard fought uh uh primary I don't know
the answer yet one way or the other so
the importance and the interest in
looking at these betting numbers relates
to the things we're going to look at
next on the show which include other
prominent Republicans turning on Trump
media Outlets turning on Trump this
election and the disaster of Trump's
failed critical contested endorsements
and we'll give you the list again later
many of you know the list already it has
opened the door for many Republicans and
media Outlets to just say this is my
opportunity to turn on Donald Trump so
the numbers right now in polling we
actually don't have new 2024 Republican
nominee polling since the election we'll
have it maybe tomorrow or Wednesday and
it'll be interesting to look at in the
betting markets
in the betting markets the favor has
turned towards Ron DeSantis over Donald
Trump and that informs what we are going
to talk about next the floodgates have
been opened by the humiliating
endorsement losses last week for Donald
Trump and now former vice president Mike
Pence is trashing the very president
that he served under Mike Pence is now
not mincing words and he is saying Trump
was Reckless and he endangered my family
what a brave former vice president right
sorry that's me choking on the absurdity
of it this guy's pathetic this guy is
pathetic you had to wait until five days
after the midterm to say what Trump did
was disgusting and he endangered my
family etc etc no the time to say it was
right after the January 6 riots and
before the 2022 midterms and Mike Pence
is now taking advantage of the fact that
Trump is as weak as he's been in a long
time and everybody's turning against him
not everybody but many are turning
against him to say the following now
it's still notable
he said this on ABC to David Muir
uh it's still notable because I don't
remember of any modern historical
example of a vice president and a
president turning on each other to this
degree it's emblematic of the
dysfunction that always existed in the
Trump White House here's Mike Pence
members were barricaded inside the house
chamber
and in the middle of it all
you can see that the president has
tweeted
2 24 PM the president tweets Mike Pence
didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done
and this is a dramatic pause here the
video hasn't stopped
it angered me
um
but I turned to my daughter who was
standing nearby
right and I said it doesn't take courage
to break the law
takes courage to uphold the law I mean
the president's words were Reckless
it was clear he decided to be part of
the problem
yeah
um
Mike Pence
should have said all of this before
he now found the
testicular fortitude to use a less crass
phrase
to come out and say this
but why not say it before the midterms
dispense feel safe now
because a lot of the trump-backed
candidates failed
it's cowardly to a degree
if you click now I know some of you are
going to say oh but David sir he has a
book coming out and it makes sense to
wait because he doesn't want to hurt the
Republicans that he likes oh I get why
he's waiting trust me I understand why
he's waiting but it's cowardly in the
sense that if Mike Pence really wants us
to believe he is the patriot who puts
country above all else no matter what
then it should be seen as his
responsibility to at the immediate point
at which he believed something as
significant as this was a reckless
president I served under who endangered
me and my family
if that is his belief
you don't wait to strategically time
that that doesn't make any sense unless
you're number one Guiding Light is
actually something different and with
Pence it is always what is best for him
now he's correct I don't deny that what
Pence is saying is accurate Trump was
completely Reckless on January 6th
Trump's actions did and his words did
endanger Pence and his family where they
were you know building a Gallows and
saying hang Mike Pence and they still
hate Pence but Pence is a coward at the
end of the day and uh he should have
been saying this six months ago he could
have been saying this almost two years
ago right 22 months ago when the riots
actually happened so Pence is he setting
up his own run for 2024 we have no idea
at this point in time but he's saying
things that are of course true but he
should have said a long time ago want to
see what happens when mental illness
combines with cult membership combines
with too much time on people's hands
well it's Carrie Lake supporters Kerry
lake is very rapidly heading towards
what is likely but not yet guaranteed to
be a loss in the Arizona gubernatorial
election this is very good for the
residents of Arizona Kerry lake is one
of the worst people to run in this cycle
right up there with mastriano and Blake
Masters and Herschel Walker and a few
others it is of course a situation that
Kerry Lake and her supporters have
backed themselves into a corner around
because they were insisting it's rigged
there will be fraud and there if if
there is not fraud I will win I will win
I will win and even as recently as I
think it was yesterday Carrie Lake was
saying I'm going to win it doesn't
really look like Kerry lake is going to
win and so her supporters showed up in
Maricopa County and at other ballot
counting centers and they are mixing
religion with mental illness with cult
membership with having too much time on
their hands here is one clip in which
they are demanding that the military
step in and just do a new election I
guess this election was fake they want a
real election by which they mean one in
which Carrie Lake wins
as it is in heaven give us this day
I want all of you to say a prayer right
now we the people are requesting
military step in and redo our election
requests denied sir
walls it's full our government is full
of corrupt people
yeah
um there were a bunch of these people
out here's one person with a megaphone
who was shouting common Shadow
government tropes where uh wealthy men
often they just happen to be Jewish men
are actually in control
Morgan
that's right
Rockefeller Rothschild and JP Morgan
um then there is another Kerry Lake
supporter calling for a new election and
remember
that they are serious folks the U.S is
now seen as the joke where when your
candidate loses you say we need a new
election and Trump even called for it he
actually called for a new electron not a
new election we'll get to that a little
bit later I I believe at this point we
need to just have a new election at this
point now that it's pretty damn clear
Kerry lake is going to lose now we are
actually ready to say we need a totally
new election and we need to do paper
ballots and we need to do it all in one
day and be done with it we can't expect
it's an absurd notion to sit here and
play this charade and act like after
this counting that we won't have tainted
results either way what he means is it's
hard to believe Carrie Lake will win
after the election is over so we should
just really redo this entire election
yep do it all over again and then
certainly an idea that Trump likes and
then another another point they were
chanting count the legal votes this is
another true well yeah sure there's lots
of votes that count but you're counting
illegal votes only count the legal ones
count the legal
League count the legal votes count to
Legal votes count the legal votes
listen you know this routine now it's
the same routine every election it's the
same that it's just that it's if we lost
it was rigged
stolen there were ballot dumps we need a
new election it was all fake fake fake
rig grigged uh they say nothing in the
races that they won they say nothing in
those races Tim Scott's race in South
Carolina have you heard a peep out of
them about that one of course not
uh Brian Kemp in Georgia they're not
saying a word they're not saying
the Herschel Walker oh very much rigged
Brian Kemp Stacey Abrams same ballots
Stacy Abrams lost genuinely Brian Kemp
won genuinely that's really the result
they say oh no no no that one's real
that one's very real the U.S is a joke
where we win it's fair if we lose it was
rigged according to these very same
people Tucker Carlson pushed a
conspiracy theory on Kerry Lake that was
so crazy that Kerry Lake almost didn't
go for it but she still kind of did
there's really no conspiracy theory too
insane for Carrie Lake remember that
Kerry lake is running for governor in
Arizona
she I have my fingers crossed she seems
to be going in the direction of losing
and we'll look at the latest numbers in
a moment Tucker Carlson pushes The
Conspiracy Theory that her opponent
Katie Hobbs
wasn't worried about the election
because Katie Hobbs is running the
election and knew that she was going to
steal it and Kerry Lake recognizes she
can't just come out and say you know
Tucker that's exactly what it is but she
basically says that Tucker isn't wrong
check this out so your opponent is the
Secretary of State
um
she didn't campaign much and she didn't
seem like she needed a campaign a lot
she never debated you and some are
smirking online that well of course she
was always confident uh in her Victory
what's your view of that very common
take on the race
you're trying to get me to say something
that might get me in trouble no no it's
just I've read 50 people say that folks
50 Reddit commenters said it and that's
why Tucker is bringing it up
that that means people are so
distrustful what they're insinuating is
that she knew she could sit back hide in
the basement do nothing that's exactly
what Tucker is saying and when due to
cheating that's what they're insinuating
and I understand why they wouldn't
insinuate that because we've had such
terrible elections they're run poorly
they're ripe with fraud
so your opponent this is you know it
almost seems like Carrie lake is going
to hesitate before jumping in on that
one because it could quote get her in
trouble but then actually she does go
for it and he explains he he says what
he's thinking and she says
the entire conspiracy theory unless she
follows it with but I don't believe that
that's true it's very clear that she's
also accepting the very same conspiracy
theory and understand the implication
Tucker Read 50 people said it
so it must be true that's now what the
guy who says you can't trust anything
you read anywhere nobody the media won't
tell you the truth social media is
filled with lies well Tucker read that
50 people wrote this on the internet
could have been Twitter could have been
Reddit who knows and so it must be true
so let's look at the latest numbers
right now right now with 93 percent of
the vote in
Katie Hobbs is leading by one point over
Kerry Lake which is about 26 000 votes
the analyzes I've read are that the
remaining ballots are unlikely to go so
much in Kerry Lake's favor that they
would put her ahead
until it's over
we wait and see make sure you're
following us on Instagram at
davidpackman show and you can follow me
on Instagram at david.pakman quick break
and right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well
Donald Trump appears to have admitted to
a major crime during his latest childish
tantrum insane meltdown the equivalent
of I don't know a little kid pooping in
the sandbox because it's time to go home
Donald Trump has now alleged that he
helped Ron DeSantis in his 2018 election
by sending in the FBI
to do what it's not even clear clearly
some kind of election interference this
you absolutely have to see Trump posting
on his platform truth social
quote I also fixed his campaign
which had completely Fallen apart I was
all in for Ron and he beat Gillum but
after the race race is capitalized we
don't know why you never know why but
after the race when votes were being
stolen by the corrupt capital E election
process in Broward County and Ron was
going down 10 000 votes a day along with
now Senator Rick Scott
I sent in the FBI and the U.S attorneys
and the ballot theft immediately ended
just prior to them running out of the
votes necessary to win I stopped his
election from being stolen
Trump did what
Trump sent in the FBI
to to do what to stop ballots from being
counted ballots which were increasingly
going for Andrew Gillum Trump is either
casually admitting to using federal
agencies to interfere in a state
election or for some reason he's making
it up and lying about it which makes him
even more depraved and unhinged which
one do you think that it is how is this
an allegation that the Department of
Justice doesn't follow up on using
federal agencies to interfere with the
state election that UC is turning
against the way you want it to go is it
to stop the ballot counting is it to
ensure only certain ballots are counted
what is it that Trump is even claiming
that he did and even if the scenario is
Trump's lying and making this up there
is almost always a grain of Truth to
some of these things what did Donald
Trump do we have no idea but he appears
to be admitting to Crim criminality now
there's another aspect to this that's
important to consider as well notice
that
when it comes to the search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago I know some of you know
exactly where I'm going with this with
the Mar-A-Lago search warrant Trump's
criticism and the criticism of Steve
Bannon and Hannity and you know all
these people the criticism is
the Biden Administration is using the
FBI
as a political tool the Biden
Administration is politicizing and
weaponizing what's supposed to be a law
enforcement agency
it doesn't appear that that's what's
happening everything was done 100
correctly when it comes to the search
warrant
but what Donald Trump is saying is I'm
actually the one who did it I
politically used the FBI
to go into Florida
and I I guess he's saying to stop the
vet the vote count that was turning in
Andrew gillum's favor
it is insane the degree to which these
allegations end up being confessions
this one just took a little while when
it came to
summer of 2020. they are going to try to
steal an election they don't win talking
about Democrats well within just a
couple months we figured out oh Trump
was going to try to steal an election
that he didn't actually win the
allegation was a confession about what
they were going to do and there's been
numerous examples of this oh Hillary
Clinton isn't going to safeguard and
properly handle classified and sensitive
documents well it took a few years but
we figured out oh actually it's Trump
who wasn't going to safeguard and
seriously handle those documents we that
allegation was also a confession and now
since Joe Biden became president and in
particular since the search warrant was
executed at Mar-A-Lago oh this is a this
is a presidency that is politicizing and
weaponizing the FBI against political
opponents
Trump seems to be admitting to having
done exactly that
in favor of his then Ally Ron DeSantis
and against the uh political opponent
Andrew Gillum another allegation which
appears to be a confession or Trump is
just lying about the fact that he
committed a crime if Trump did this it
is illegal Donald Trump is demanding a
redo of the 2022 election in Arizona
in what we are calling an electron rant
an electron rant this is really up there
as an iconic presidential moment of all
time and you'll see what I mean in a
moment Donald Trump posting to his
platform truth social truth essential
quote so in Maricopa County they are at
it again voting machines in large
numbers didn't work but only in
Republican districts remember this isn't
true there were like a couple tabulators
that had an issue everything was fine
people were forced to wait for hours
then got exhausted or had other things
to do and left the voting Lines by the
thousands even Kerry Lake was taken to a
liberal Democrat District in order to
vote others weren't so lucky now
remember
nobody was told to leave and go to other
polling places it was a republican who
was actually doing that okay this is a
scam and voter fraud no different than
stuffing the ballot boxes they stole the
capital E electron from Blake Masters do
election over again ladies and gentlemen
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
we do things not because they are easy
but because they are hard
they stole the electron due election
over again really an iconic moment
inspiring and just Electric in
presidential statements of History
forget the typo okay for a second as
funny as it is it is shocking that a
former president still doesn't know how
the vote counting process works it
times do we have to do this until Trump
will understand or any of them quite
frankly
why it is that votes are counted the way
they're accounted and I think it's
important to remind people again in many
of these states the votes are counted
the way they are counted because of
Republican legislatures that have put in
place the rules for how the vote count
Works add to that by the way that at
this point the most scrutinized state in
terms of voting security is probably
Arizona maybe Pennsylvania to some
degree because of what happened in 2020
but there is no state that is more
scrutinized than Arizona
within Arizona
I don't think there's any County more
scrutinized than Maricopa County at this
point in time because of what happened
in 2020 thanks to Trump in other words
because of all the claims Trump made in
2020 about Arizona Arizona and Maricopa
County are now insanely scrutinized even
though there's no particular need to do
it and now he's saying oh yeah there was
fraud again it was fraught just as
fraudulent again and uh it is
unbelievable that people continue to
fall for this but sadly this is now
standard operating procedure we we
didn't know
back in uh 2020. whether
it was rigged it was stolen would become
a broader calling card or a more
frequent refrain for Republicans but it
is very clear that that is now the case
if they lose it was rigged the world is
laughing and that's where we are at this
point in time
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
last week someone uh I think it was a
voicemail or maybe someone wrote to me
and said David do you think Herschel
Walker understands uh how the runoff
works and the fact that because no one
got 50 in Georgia now there's a runoff
just between him and and Raphael Warnock
I said I have no clue what Herschel
Walker does or doesn't understand but I
did have a curiosity as to what sorts of
public statements and appearances was
Herschel Walker going to make in this uh
intermediate period between the November
election and the December 6 runoff and
it's completely incoherent so I can't
tell you for sure whether Herschel
Walker understands the runoff but he
seems very confused about a bunch of
other things in this first clip Herschel
Walker says we are the best country in
the United States
I don't know that he's wrong about that
do you know we're the greatest country
in the United States in the world
because we have a United States military
yep we are the best country in the
United States and the world because of
the military then Herschel Walker does
seem to be suffering from a touch of
what we call the Trump delusion where he
believes only he can save America now
remember Trump said that Trump said only
he can help solve many issues I think in
2015 2016 Trump was saying only I can
fix health care we never even got his
health care plan
uh only he can fix trade and of course
he didn't
uh and this seems to now be I don't know
that a requirement but it certainly
seems beneficial and to a degree it
makes sense if you are completely
unqualified
hypocritical
unethical
clueless and have no business in elected
office you first have to convince
yourself that you have some business
running and in order to do that you
probably tell yourselves lies like the
entire country is depending on this and
that's exactly what he said to Larry
Kudlow I love the United States of
America if I do not win that seat we may
not recognize America as soon as they
get back in control because they seem
not to like America I want America to be
great I want every kid in America to
have that America's Dream well I can
tell you right now if I don't win that
seat no other American will ever have
that America dream again yep the entire
American Dream depends on Herschel
Walker who's completely unqualified and
doesn't know up from down when it comes
to policy if he doesn't win
no kid in America will ever achieve the
American dream that's a sickness that is
unique to the Republican party you hear
you know we talk about in many areas
Democrats and Republicans are more or
less the same and in other areas they're
very different
this particular sort of uh God complex
I don't see on the left I just don't see
it even Barack Obama who knew he would
be the first black president half black
of course as We Know
even when he was asked about like are is
this the most important thing a black
person whatever there was a statement
and he said well listen it's important
but think about all of these other
people and he listed a half dozen other
people this is a unique type of delusion
that you see on the right
here is a uh oh here's Walker again
continuing to talk about pronouns and I
I really don't know that he knows what
pronouns are I'm increasingly suspicious
but yet they bring it pronouns
they're bringing pronouns in our
military right so his pronoun gonna be
former Senator Pro now this is pronoun
former Senator yes Rafael warnock's
pronouns are going to be former Senator
I have it on good authority that if he
wins Herschel Walker is going to launch
a brutal assault on prepositional
phrases the likes of which you have
never even dreamed about Ted Cruz
appeared alongside Herschel Walker on
Fox News and he just kind of nodded
along as Herschel Walker made no sense
and visibly struggled to use language to
communicate He's a hypocrite and being a
pastor I say this how can he keep the
almighty old to the almighty God and he
keep it for them he hadn't came for
neither nobody so that proves the type
of man he really is all right so Cruz
you're the leader Ted Cruz's head it's
like a bobble head doll Locker here
you're going to have to open up some
holes for Herschel what yeah it's all
just so so so great guys and then here
is sort of like the cherry on top uh
Laura Ingraham on Fox News interviewing
Herschel Walker
they said we're in overtime
we're in overtime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
Georgia is the third state that could
decide the fate of the Senate and with
its second runoff turns out it won't
right because Democrats held the Senate
since this interview aired in just as
many years it's also the second most
expensive race this cycle totaling 262
million dollars by the way one of the
things these right Wingers are able to
do is just turn a fact into it like a a
criticism of Democrats this is a super
expensive race and they they act as if
that's proof that you should vote for
Walker in some way okay yeah the race
was expensive and Walker is incompetent
joining us now is the Republican
Herschel Walker who is really good in
overtime I have to say Georgia Senate
candidate Herschel great to see you
tonight as always
um how are you feeling right now after
this wild week where we have so many
races across the country still undecided
and you're heading to this runoff
well I feel pretty good uh the reason
why I'm still fighting for the people of
Georgia uh you know that's what I got in
this race about it was about the people
of Georgia that they were not
represented well in Washington we have a
senator that seemed to be representing
Washington our California New York not
Georgia and Georgia need a champion and
I'm that champion because I'm going to
get into Washington and let the people
voices be heard and let the people know
that they'll have that champion there
because Senator Walnut has not done it
since he went to Washington less than
two years people see where we're at
Herschel McConnell Mitch McConnell is
turning to Governor camp for help in
this race Politico is reporting that
Kemp is loaning his get out the vote
machine to the Senate's GOP voter
turnout efforts giving the party entree
I'm curious what he'll say about this
political team that is increasingly
viewed as one of the gop's most
formidable State operations and at the
same time we understand the Democrats
have already invested seven million
dollars in get out the vote efforts
which sounds like ballot harvesting to
me which is legal in your state
listen they're spending money on this
election there's got to be something
illegal there
um what's the way to win this race now
with the remaining weeks that you have
well you know it's such a short time and
uh you know the Democrat is trying to
buy this seat yeah exactly that money
spent by the Democrats is to buy the
seat whereas uh all the money spent on
the behalf of Herschel Walker is just
democracy or whatever the case may be
this is a crucial race it's now about 51
rather than 50 and making Joe manchin
irrelevant so we are going to be
following that race closely we are going
to be activating around that race we'll
have more information for you soon hey I
have to tell you speaking of Herschel
Walker some of you may or may not know
Herschel Walker's son Christian Walker
is also a right-winger he's also a
social media influencer and he turned
against his father Herschel Walker for
being an absent dad and for endangering
him and his mom and so many different
things Herschel Walker's son Christian
Walker actually made a lot of sense
talking about Donald Trump's endorsement
record and this does not mean that I now
agree with Christian Walker's worldview
or anything like it but on this
particular issue Christian Walker
correctly assesses the absurdity of the
endorsement record that Donald Trump is
touting take a listen to this y'all stop
with this endorsement lie if I endorsed
Ron DeSantis a week before his election
could I go see he won because of me no
he was gonna win anyways he was gonna
win it's a Florida and he's done a great
job just like if I win endorse a
republican in Alabama and was like see
my endorsements are amazing right no I'm
pretty sure Republican was gonna win in
Alabama right just like if a Democrat
endorsed Gavin Newsom he would he's
gonna win done and endure you get to you
get to brag about your endorsement in
toss-up States or whatever that's what
we're that's what I'm looking for did
your endorsements win in toss-up states
where we had a chance then lost or then
won
you get to brag about endorsements if
you have a republican win in a blue
state but not Republicans in seats we've
had for decades this is spot on and I
have to say I'm glad that there is a
right winger including an extremist
right-winger like Christian Walker
who is saying this when Trump and other
pro-trump Republicans talk about listen
209 was the record or maybe now it's 250
and 15 or whatever what matters are the
contested elections of consequence okay
DeSantis was winning by 12. in the polls
ultimately 1 by 19. Trump held off on
saying almost anything about DeSantis
until the very end didn't even invite
him to his rally the Sunday before the
election and counts DeSantis as one of
his wins what matters is whether you can
deliver victories either when there is a
contested primary and you influence the
primary and subsequently the person you
choose goes on to win or whether you can
influence a toss-up state
he endorsed Mehmet Oz Trump did and Oz
lost
he endorsed Doug mastriano and mastriano
lost that was a critical race of
significant importance he endorsed Tudor
Dixon in Michigan for governor and
Gretchen Whitmer one he endorsed Blake
Masters an important senate seat in
Arizona Mark Kelly won he endorsed Kerry
Lake it looks like Kerry lake is going
to lose he endorsed Jr Majewski and John
Gibbs both of whom I interviewed check
out those interviews in their respective
uh congressional districts they both
lost those are the endorsements that are
actually relevant endorsing incumbents
republican nominees in safe seats
waiting until the last minute when
you've already seen how all of the
polling shakes out there's nothing
remarkable about that whatsoever by the
way one more I I was curious how is
Christian Walker reacting to what's
going on in Georgia because his own
father is now in a runoff election
against Rafael Warnock there take a
listen
dinner
so is everyone saying we had a great
midterm season we just lost the Senate
before we even get to the Georgia runoff
so even if we win Georgia we've already
lost because if we win Georgia it would
go to a tie and the vice president is
the tiebreaker and she's a demo accurate
explanation of how the Senate works very
good so for everyone celebrating the
midterm saying we did so good
congratulations we lost congratulations
hope you expect us to celebrate you
think you can Gaslight everyone into
saying we had a great midterms we lost
very easy seats to pick up we could have
easily won
good job tired of all this winning no
I'm sick of losing okay so Christian
Walker shot out of a cannon there and a
lot of what he's been saying lately
really does make sense he will not be
campaigning for his father Herschel
Walker we will certainly be working for
Raphael Warnock and um I uh we're still
taking ideas for what we should do
should we do a sort of fundraiser
Telethon live stream where the more
money we raise for Warnock the longer
the stream goes should we do I don't
know what the privacy rules would be
around some kind of live phone banking I
just don't know we're trying to figure
it out but if you have ideas of how to
ensure
that Democrats get 51 seats rather than
just the 50 and make Joe manchin
irrelevant email info
davidpackman.com we have a voicemail
number that number is 219 to David P
there's this guy Eric from Mass who has
been
um calling in with all sorts of coveted
conspiracy theories since the start of
the pandemic I told you last week that
Donald Trump has been asking around
about ways that he might be able to
imprison journalists adversarial to him
if he were to become the president of
the United States again
and I think imprisoning journalists for
their opinions is bad uh Eric from Mass
says I should be imprisoned for the
things I said about covid listen to this
hey David to start from that so just
watched the thing I put about Trump and
the journalists looks like you might be
shooting Advanced
um after all the lives and stuff with
coven and all the people you got hurt
with vaccines you know they were live
but you don't want accountability for
what you did
lying to people scaring people you know
Eric still seems to struggle with the
understanding that I don't create any
views or make assertions myself about
vaccines or covet
I I I'm a commentator
I bring to you
the best synthesis that I've done of the
Medical Science and Eric continues to
talk to me as if I'm coming up with the
information about how vaccines work or
anything about covet it's very strange
all over a common cold
make people wear masks make kids wear
masks disgusting yeah I mean I didn't do
anything I didn't make anyone do
anything absolutely disgusting what you
did and promoted and you must be
shutting your pants thinking that
accountability is coming and that's one
thing with you Democrats you never
ever
from pregnancy to anything else take
accountability for your own actions but
you get it you got people killed you got
people hurt okay
by the way
Democrats don't take accountability for
pregnancy
have you heard of Herschel Walker so
Eric from Mass still struggling with
thinking and Common Sense
I predict I will not be imprisoned for
my reporting on vaccines maybe there's a
place that will take your bet on that I
would not bet on me being imprisoned for
covet coverage we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad we are going to go through all of
the scenarios in the House of
Representatives that could lead to
Republican control
or that could lead to democratic control
not a conversation I expected to be
having with you today that's for sure
we're also going to talk about new
polling which went to student loan uh
borrowers and said if you had student
loan forgiveness or for those who were
getting it what do you plan to use the
money for and the answers were very
interesting and a lot of people
misunderstand the answers a lot of
people I don't know if deliberately or
not
seem to be thinking oh see their answers
to what they're going to spend the money
on proves it wasn't a good idea to do
the forgiveness
very much the opposite we will talk
about that and number three Dave
Chappelle hosted Saturday Night Live
over the weekend and one of the things
he did during his monologue was he
criticized Kanye West he criticized
Kyrie Irving for their anti-semitic
statements but in so doing
Dave Chappelle reinforced some of those
very same anti-semitic tropes
very disappointing to see the right
loved it the right now they see Dave
Chappelle as their hero but um it was
pretty bad so we're going to talk about
that on today's bonus show as well sign
up at join
Pacman
.com join pacman.com you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now I believe 24
starts tomorrow with Donald Trump's
announcement although now there are
rumors it might only be remarks it might
not be an announcement well we will
figure it out very quickly uh
joinpakman.com coupon code 24 starts now
we will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back here tomorrow